à l'extrême sud du liban
un territoire sous haute surveillance
à la frontière avec israël et la syrie
ma destination ce village chabar perché
dans les montagnes à portée de tirs des
combattants de l'état islamique basée en
syrie
pour y accéder je suis escorté par les
soldats des nations unies
la route est interdite aux étrangers
sont une autorisation spéciale
ramiz mon guide est un enfant du pays
cette journée pour lui particulière
avec tous les hommes du village ils
défilent derrière un cercueil
ici le défunt était un homme important
c'était un homme que l'on craignait
il était drôle et il aimait faire le
bien
en même temps c'était un homme
d'affaires
business était un peu spécial il était
marchand d'armes
mais bon c'est tout
rien d'étonnant pour ce village la
contrebande y est une tradition
les armes circulent ainsi que les hommes
venus de syrie pour surveiller ces
migrants ramiz installé à ses frais des
caméras de surveillance partout dans le
village
il redoute des infiltrations de
combattants de l'état islamique
là c'est l'image de la première caméra
et ensuite la deuxième il y en a deux
autres
ici vous êtes à la frontière vous avez
part de l'état islamique
bref moi j'ai peur du lendemain j'ai
peur que l'on ne puisse plus maîtriser
la situation
j'ai peur que l'on soit chassé de notre
village
j'ai peur que les réfugiés syriens qui
vivent avec nous aujourd'hui deviennent
des ennemis
j'ai peur de tout ça
[Musique]
pour empêcher ces combattants radicaux
de s'infiltrer les hommes du village ont
instauré un couvre-feu à partir de 21h
ils ont formé une milice armée qui
jettent en prison tout étranger
circulant dans la ville
à la nuit tombée ils scrutent chaque
ruelle du village à l'affût du moindre
mouvement
nous nous dirigeons vers les montagnes
fait des montagnes de schiphol
c'est la route de la frontière oui la
frontière avec la syrie c'est
aujourd'hui le principal problème du
liban
elle risque de raviver les affrontements
entre les communautés
il y à 40 ans la guerre civile qui avait
déchiré le pays opposés déjà des milices
communautaire
les combats avaient fait plus de 140000
mans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui les trois principales
communautés du pays sunnite chiite et
chrétienne
ça remonte à nouveau
la nouvelle gare du liban a peut-être
déjà commencé
[Musique]
où
mon voyage commence à 30 km de la
frontière syrienne
dans la deuxième ville du liban tripoli
surnommée la petite scierie
dans cette ville à majorité sunnite
la population soutient la rébellion si
rien contre le dictateur bachar al assad
l'armée libanaise est présente à chaque
coin de rue mais ces dernières années
dans certains quartiers elle n'a pas pu
empêcher les règlements de compte les
tueries entre habitants
rodolphe un enfant de batz habana
quartier populaire de tripoli on est le
témoin il ne peut que constater les
dégâts
c'est votre quartier vous vivez ici
c'est ici que je vis là vous n'avez plus
que le quart d'un immeuble le reste
c'était sont des actes de la guerre là
il ya des impacts de balles
là c'est un espace pour les enfants
pouvaient être en train de jouer les
balles retentissait un enfant arrivé à
fuir un autre était blessé et reste
handicapé à vie
la vie est difficile
le quartier vite au rythme du conflit
syrien avec son look branché rodolphe
des notes dans cette ville conservatrice
son destin il le résume en quelques mots
mais depuis que je suis conscient de ce
qui se passe autour de moi je ne vis que
dans la guerre
mon grand père m'a dit je suis né dans
la guerre toi tu es né dans la guerre
étaient enfants vont être dans la guerre
c'est le destin de notre famille lien
sur les murs des affiches de jeunes du
quartier
regarde là bas la photo d'un martyr la
même
ce sont celles de ses meilleurs amis
ils sont morts les armes à la main
pour amy c'est omar
il est mort très jeune
à côté de leur portrait
le drapeau noir du 10 m
ces jeunes se battait au côté des
radicaux
ici l'islam est devenu synonyme de lutte
armée
à 500 mètres de là dans un autre
quartier
personne ne soutient les djihadistes
mais leurs ennemis bachar al assad
les règlements de comptes entre ces
quartiers voisins sont fréquents parfois
même des attentats kamikazes
ce café qui affiche portes closes on a
été la cible
omar était un client régulier
il répare les dégâts
il venait ici tous les soirs le jour du
drame sa fille était malade il a tardé à
rejoindre ses amis il a échappé à la
mort
le kamikaze a failli trébucher sur la
table des gars lui ont dit fais
attention à toi mon gars il s'est
positionné ici et il a actionné sa bombe
comme ça
bilan 7 morts et 36 blessés
l'état islamique est arrivée en syrie en
irak et maintenant il est arrivé au
liban
les djihadistes frappe partout
aujourd'hui il frappe à beyrouth à
tripoli
même en france ou aux états unis ils
sont partout ils se font exploser pour
tuer des innocents
il prend se rapprocher de dieu mais
c'est vers l'enfer qu'ils se dirigeaient
les deux kamikazes étaient ses voisins
il venait du quartier dordogne
j'ai pu rencontrer l'un de ces habitants
prêt lui aussi à mourir pour le jihad il
a accepté de me parler sous couvert
d'anonymat
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi votre avis les jeunes d'ici
rejoint les djihadistes
nous sommes des musulmans sunnites et
c'est notre devoir de le faire
c'est notre charia qui nous l'imposent
il ya toujours la guerre ici c'est
toujours nous les musulmans sunnites qui
ont payé le prix
on résiste non
mais ce que vous avez des armes
les armes ne sont pas un souci si on
démarre les combats en une demi-heure
les armes seront là
[Musique]
comment ça on nous livre discrètement
avec des pick up il ya mille façons d'en
avoir on utilise même débarquent par la
mer
comment ces jeunes en vient-il à se
radicaliser
pour comprendre
je me rends le lendemain
dans la plus grande mosquée du quartier
ici les fidèles se bousculent jusqu'en
dehors des murs de ce lieu de culte
tous sont venus pour écouter le prêche
d'une star scheer la feuille
l'imam est connu pour avoir appelé les
soldats libanais à ne pas combattre les
djihadistes une mouvance qu'il soutient
ouvertement
et il profite de ma présence pour faire
passer un message à la france
il n'y a pas si longtemps des députés
français ont rendu visite à bachar
el-assad
vous imaginez il discutait avec bachar
el-assad de la manière de combattre le
terrorisme
ils veulent combattre le terrorisme aux
côtés du plus grand terroriste de
l'histoire
que dieu ne démolisse lui et ses
soutiens
apparemment la salle partagent ses idées
et ses prières avec ferveur que dieu
donne la victoire à nos frères au liban
en irak en syrie en palestine et partout
dans le monde
ouais
l'imam quittent les lieux sous la
protection de son garde du corps
à l'extérieur c'est sombre et col des
billets pour les plus démunis
lui reçoit six fidèles dans une salle à
part
il vient lui demander conseil ou de
laine
ils attendent parfois des heures pour un
entretien comment cet homme influent et
respecté justifie t-il son soutien aux
djihadistes de l'état islamique ou de
shabbat sinon cela une organisation
terroriste affilié à al qaïda
quel est votre avis sur les djihadistes
de java tendance là pour nous en europe
ce sont des terroristes
commence à des terroristes
parce qu'ils défendent leur dignité
qu'est ce que tu sais toi du terrorisme
mettons nous d'accord sur la définition
du terrorisme
vous qu'on sait que quelqu'un qui défend
sa famille ses enfants son pays sa
liberté et sa dignité et c'est un
terroriste
dans ce cas les français aussi sont des
terroristes à la révolution française
ils ont défendu leur liberté et leur
droit
faire des terroristes des résistants
un discours qui trouve un écho ici
surtout auprès des jeunes
c'est le quartier le plus peuplé du
liban les plus déshérités
c'est celui qui habite rogers il me fait
visiter l'appartement de son oncle ou
plutôt ce qu'il en reste après un
bombardement
[Musique]
pendant les tirs il y avait des gens qui
vivaient ici c'est moche
voilà le quartier vous convient s'il a
vu comment on vit
comme pro dole les gens d'ici n'ont que
peu de perspectives d'avenir
ce désespoir et cette misère sont le
terreau de l'état islamique
[Musique]
trop dormi dans un deux pièces avec sept
membres de sa famille
je vais grand ma mère il y a quelques
mois encore il était champion du liban
de kickboxing une star du quartier
une blessure au genou a mis fin à sa
passion
depuis il noie son désarroi dans les
vapeurs de la chicha
j'ai démarré ma carrière sportive ici
dans cette pièce
j'ai réalisé mes premiers mouvements ici
seul sans l'aide de personne
j'ai bossé dur pour atteindre le sommet
j'y suis arrivé et maintenant c'est fini
elle fera partie tu as refusé de porter
des armes
oui bien sûr je n'aime pas les armes
je n'aime pas en avoir sur moi
l'histoire
nous
a empêchés
crowder résistent encore à l'appel des
armes
mais dans sa rue pour quelques billets
beaucoup d'un m'affirmait prêt à
s'engager
on dit qu ici avec le chômage et la
misère les jeunes prennent les armes ou
partent en syrie
on n'a pas de travail il suffit que l'on
nous donne quelques pièces pour partir
faire la guerre
on n'a rien
la misère qui nous pousse à ça
partout dans le quartier les militaires
semblent sous tension
arrêter de fumer mais je sais qu'il ne
faut pas filmer l'armée
je ne filme que les façades délabrées
leur présence à chaque coin de rue
semble agacer les habitants
l'armée nous jette en prison sans raison
les jeunes peuvent avoir envie de se
faire exploser je ne sais pas moi
arrêtent de filmer
je découvre qu ici l'armée libanaise
n'est pas considéré comme un pouvoir
légitime mais plutôt comme une force
d'occupation
elle est accusée de soutenir leurs
ennemis bachar al assad
pourquoi une telle défiance entre
l'armée et la population de tripoli
pour répondre à cette question
je prends la route de beyrouth la
capitale
je me rends au meeting du hezbollah le
parti chiite
c'est le mieux organisé et le plus armé
du pays
allié de bachar al assad
une position de plus en plus partagée
dans les rangs de l'armée libanaise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la salle chauffée par des images de
propagande
attend avec impatience le discours de
son chef hassan nasrallah
[Applaudissements]
pour des raisons de sécurité
il n'intervient que par liaison vidéo
le monde entier est d'accord pour dire
que les djihadistes qui se nomme états
islamiques sont une vraie menace pour la
sécurité de la région et pour celle du
monde
l'état islamique chercherait à annexer
le liban qui lui offrirait ainsi un
accès à la méditerranée
le hezbollah se présente comme un
rempart contre les radicaux
alors qu'il est lui même classé parmi
les organisations terroristes par les
américains
aujourd'hui à la frontière il y à l'état
islamique et ja battle n'ose pas
l'état islamique existe en libye aux
portes de bagdad et il est à nos
frontières
celui qui veut décider de l'avenir du
liban doit s'investir dans l'avenir de
la région
en soutenant son allié bachar al assad
le hezbollah est accusé d'entraîner le
liban dans une guerre contre l'état
islamique
m
dans ce meeting je ne suis pas autorisé
à poser librement des questions
publiques
[Applaudissements]
il y a huit mois à la frontière syrienne
26 soldats libanais ont été pris en
otage par des djihadistes à beyrouth
derrière ces barbelés leurs familles
réclament leur libération
elles ont installé des tentes sous les
fenêtres du parlement
c'est lui mon frère frei et
pierre geagea
il ya les forts ceux qui sont là-haut
sont morts j'avais
on aime ceux du bal sont encore en vie
des soldats qui étaient chargés de
garder la frontière libanaise
cet homme réorganise sa vie ici
il s'est promis de ne pas rentrer chez
lui sans son fils mais il ne fait pas
confiance à l'état libanais pour le
libérer
c'est le plus grand problème que peut
rencontrer un pays le kidnapping de ses
propres soldats sur leurs terres
sans que le gouvernement ne puisse les
libérer
un gouvernement impuissant
alors chacun se replie vers sa
communauté
entre les chiites et les sunnites
la gare a déjà commencé dans certaines
régions
et une troisième communauté libanaise a
peur d'être entraînés dans le conflit
les chrétiens
[Musique]
mon voyage mans mène maintenant nord-est
du liban arras baalbeck le village
chrétien le plus proche de la frontière
syrienne
c'est dans ces collines que les 26
soldats libanais ont été enlevés par des
djihadistes
race baalbeck est une enclave chrétienne
en terre musulmane
l'armée libanaise la placé sous haute
surveillance
face aux dangers djihadistes les
habitants ressentent plus que jamais le
besoin de prier ensemble
adossée à l'église
la maison de assad
la famille de ce chrétien vie dans ce
village depuis plus de mille ans il
tient à ses racines et à sa terre
la vie à les rebelles ici oui
ici on n'a jamais eu problème même
pendant la guerre civile c'était calme
mais cette année avec l'état islamique
et elle ne sera non ça va
peut-être que cette nuit pendant que tu
es là une bombe nous tombera dessus
peut-être que tu vas entendre des tirs
de l'armée contre les djihadistes
il y a quelques jours un bombardement de
l'état islamique a justement frappé un
des symboles du village une église
à sapiens me montrer les dégâts
[Musique]
il y avait des gars qui étaient en
position ici pour surveiller le village
une roquette est tombée et quatre
d'entre eux ont été blessés l'un d'eux
est handicapé à vie
nous sommes un village pacifique nous
n'avons attaqué personne les djihadistes
font ça pour nous obliger à quitter le
village mais nous on y tient
les jeunes du village à sète les
retrouve ce jour là sur la colline de la
vierge ils n'ont que cet endroit pour
changer d'air il offre le plus beau
point de vue sur cette frontière tant
redoutée
lakhdari a installé des points
d'observation sur ces collines où joan
jett avec sa présence nous n'avons pas
peur nous resterons ici et nous
défendrons chaque mètre carré de ce
village
et pour ça les armes ne sont jamais loin
nous n'avons pas d'armes on préfère les
mots mais si on n'a pas le choix on a ce
qu'il faut
la nuit à cette patrouille dans les rues
de race balle bac tu écoutes
oui quelle est la situation pour vous
tout est ok
les ruelles sont désertes pas une âme
qui vive ah ça tiens me faire rencontrer
les anciens du village chaque soir ils
se réunissent dans ce local
bonjour la jeunesse vous allez bien ici
les anciens se souvient d'un autre liban
celui d'avant la guerre civile où les
communautés coexister en paix
avoir 20 ans à l'époque c'est un milité
au sein du parti communiste qui
regroupait des chrétiens des musulmans
c'est vous
c'est moi
c'est le
secrétaire général de parti communiste
qui accueillait à voir avec apparu
depuis l'essor de l'état islamique le
réunion du soir autour de l'asodia le
chauffage locales prennent une autre
tournure
l'inquiétude s'installe
nous ne maîtrisons rien
g l'avenir est sombre
nous n'avons aucune influence sur votre
futur
ça l'avenir de la région et celui des
pays occidentaux sont liés mais
ce qui se passe en syrie ou en libye
n'est pas si loin de la france ni de
l'italie
cette nuit là deux roquettes ont visé le
village
poste de contrôle de à postes de
contrôle un jeu social écoute tout est
ok pour vous
rien à signaler
sur le flanc de la colline les plus
jeunes armes à la main scrute l'horizon
il sera là est toute la nuit
partout au liban ils sont de plus en
plus nombreux à s'enrôler dans ces
milices communautaire
au terme de mon voyage je repense à ces
drapeaux noirs du djihad flottant à
tripoli j'ai le sentiment que cette
ville ne m'a pas livré tous ses secrets
l'armée libanaise vient d'emprisonner
160 jeunes soupçonnés de djihadisme
j'ai rendez vous avec leurs familles à
la gare routière de tripoli
je devais les accompagner jusqu'à la
prison de belles routes mais les choses
ne vont pas se passer comme prévu
tu fais ce trajet chaque semaine
oui chaque semaine et c'est une grande
distance 100 km à l'aller 100 km au
retour
toujours avec les familles des jeunes
oui - et les familles nous allons tous à
la prison de beyrouth tu as quelqu'un en
prison mon frère est là bas
et pourquoi est-il en prison
il est juste en prison les problèmes de
tripoli
à l'aide de fil mais il y en a marre ils
ne posent plus de questions
seul le chauffeur me parle je n'ai pas
le droit de m'adresser aux femmes agacé
il n'hésite pas à me livrer le fond de
sa pensée
les journalistes français sont des
mécréants
tu es français tué un mécréant
mais pourquoi tu dis ça nous insulter le
prophète
c'est un péché
nous sommes des musulmans et pour nous
la religion est sacrée
difficile de ne pas penser à mes
confrères de charlie hebdo
justifierait-il l'attentât sa réponse
est ambiguë
nous respectons les autres religions
mais c'est vous les journalistes qui
nous divise est
allez tu dégages je te dépose au
deuxième classement
le chauffeur me laisse au bord de la
route
comment rester neutres liban
dans le regard de l'autre on finit
souvent par devenir un ennemi
je trouve le moyen de revenir à tripoli
[Musique]
j'y retrouve rôle le jeune qui s'est
promis de ne jamais porter les armes
l'ancien champion de kick-boxing s'est
transformé en prof de break d'un ce
ca bien tes jambes
parfait
fonds devrait échapper au destin tout
tracé des jeunes de son quartier
celui de la guerre mais aura-t-il
vraiment le choix
[Applaudissements]
dites moi les jeunes la guerre est à vos
portes et vous dansez du breakdance
je vais te dire ce que signifie pour
nous le
président sont pour la vie
dansons pour la paix au lieu de détruire
de tuer on a envie que le monde est de
nous une belle image
qu'est ce qui est le mieux faire du
sport s'amuser se muscler
prendre une arme et tiré sur quelqu'un
peut comparer ces deux choix
à la pose la question
mais aujourd'hui à tripoli
ces jeunes se sentent appartenir à une
communauté avant d'être libanais
à la mosquée de son quartier
ce jour-là
randolph et l'appel à la prière
en cas de guerre il serait qu'ils le
veuillent ou non considéré comme un
représentant de sa communauté
son destin ressemble à celui de son pays
enrôlé malgré lui dans un conflit qui
n'est pas le sien
[Musique]
à
rien
[Musique]
à